il ne fallait pas arriver en retard pour
cette rencontre entre le sky rugby et
bagneux dès l'entamé les saint
quentinois mettre la pression sur leurs
adversaires
et s'il se loupe une première fois la
seconde est la bonne on joue la deuxième
minute de jeu et le sky mène déjà 7 à 0
le premier quart d'heure est sous
domination saint-quentinoise le sky news
by campent dans les 22 mètres adverses
sans réussir à inscrire le moindre point
ce qui a manqué je pense que c'est
effectivement de marquer un deuxième
essai en première mi temps on avait
l'occasion de marquer un deuxième essai
de prendre d'autres disent nos distances
on l'a pas fait et après le temps on a
une belle équipe en face qui a
expérimenté en honneur qui était pas un
match au début et qui est rentré dans le
match au fur à mesure donc résultat nous
on se retrouve on se retrouve derrière à
la fin on va dire logiquement puisque on
n'était pas loin mais mais ils ont
maîtrisé qu'à la deuxième mi temps
ban il revient en inscrivant un essai
tout en mouvement tout en puissance mais
les giboulées de mars invite dans la
partie le ballon se transforme en
savonnette les en avants se multiplient
les visiteurs réussissent tout de même à
passer devant 8 à 7 à la mi temps
au retour des vestiaires le sky rugby
commet beaucoup de fautes les balnéo les
en profite et prennent le large en
marquant un deuxième essai les points
n'évolueront plus score final 16 à 7
pour les visiteurs dans la tête on
n'était pas trop ça fait trois semaines
qu'on n'a pas joué et il faut se
remettre dedans il faut se remettre un
peu pour se remettre dans le rythme de
deux matches de championnat quoi cette
défaite n'a aucune incidence au
classement 7e le sky rugby est assuré du
maintien
il reste trois matches aux saint
quentinois avant la fin de la saison